foreign
another question here this one is from
Bethany on Facebook how do you go from
being a serious Night Owl to being an
early bird I really want and need to
make that transition hmm you've got to
make sure that like you legitimately can
work with that schedule because I think
about Josh getting up at what 3 A.M 4
a.m yeah mostly as I get up somewhere
between 3 30 and 4 45 yeah and it's like
there's a piece in me that's like man I
really admire that would love to get up
that early another piece of me uh
admires the aesthetic that Josh has um
that him and Bex have in their home
um but in order to get up at 3 30 a.m in
order to have that aesthetic there is a
fundamental change that I would have to
do in my life that for me Isn't it's
it's not worth it just to get up at 3 30
a.m because they get up at 3 30 a.m you
have to go to bed at and usually eight
o'clock maybe 7 45 right and I'm just
eating dinner at eight o'clock yeah I
think it's even worse than that because
we're told that like habit change
there's a whole lot around habit change
right now people you hear you've heard
it a thousand times in the last year
people talk about habit change and
here's one thing I'll tell you that
changing your habits won't change your
life because
you don't have the disposition to get up
at 3 30 right I don't necessarily even
want to I didn't choose to I get up that
time on my own this morning I woke up at
404 am
and I just woke up there was no alarm
that got me up now I did go to bed early
I am just predisposed to want to go to
bed earlier to get up earlier that is
the time of day that works best for me
right that's why I never prescribed this
to anyone you should wake up at 3 30. I
think that would radically disrupt
someone's life it might change your life
but it's probably going to change it for
the worse because now you're groggy
you're tired throughout the day maybe
you're experiencing brain fog you're not
getting enough sleep however I'll give
you some practical insights here if
maybe you do have that disposition but
your culture this is what happened to me
when I was in my teen late teens early
20s my culture was like you're supposed
to stay out late and so I would stay out
till midnight 1am 2 A.M
but that's not my disposition and so how
did I fix that well I started going to
bed every night at the same time yeah if
you if you have been going to bed at
eight o'clock for so long how did you
watch Family Matters before we had
streaming
he he would do VHS recordings
the whole time I just got the bootlegs
Family Matters brutally patenting you
know there's something helpful I think
about not attaching some adjustment you
might need to work for life or some new
agenda that you have to your identity
how do I become a morning person when I
am a night owl maybe it's possible for
you to just continue being the person
that you are but then to ask yourself
hey what are some adjustments I can make
to be able to meet this goal for this
period of time right because I I've
tried so many different things and I
don't think there's anything that's more
true of me than the fact that I'm a
night owl when left my own devices I I
just work better when I stay up late and
I get more done and so on however there
are some priorities I have that motivate
me to get up but beyond external
obligation when it comes to the days
we're in here
if I get up at 4 30 and I get out no
later than five man what a great drive
here it's like 45 minutes and it's just
free-flowing and I love it so much that
I'm excited to get up at that time
because I love that drive and then I get
to go to a spot that I have there's a
monastery that I go to and I can just
spend the first couple of hours of my
day meditating and if I need to sleep
I'll go to sleep right there in that
Monastery you know what I mean I got the
ball here so nobody bothers me but
I don't I don't look at myself as being
a morning person as somebody that can
ever be what Josh is by nature but it's
just an adjustment that I make because
it benefits me to make it on those days
and so maybe not putting the weight up
on yourself of redefining who you are
but just looking for some tools so here
are a few things that I do that have
helped me from a how-to perspective from
a very mechanical perspective that have
radically improved my sleep first thing
is whenever possible I go to bed at the
same time every night I go to bed the
same time every night yep second thing I
do and this is probably the most
important thing
grounding I sleep on a grounding mat I'm
not trying to sell you one uh we have a
former podcast guest Clint Ober one of
our most popular episodes ever the
grounding episode so many people have
found value and that so many people have
experienced the benefits of grounding at
night sleeping on a grounding mat yeah
which radically improves people's sleep
reduces inflammation reconnects you with
the Earth and there's a ton of science
behind it you can find the book called
earthing earthing.com and you can find
sleep mats over there as well we'll put
a link to that in the show notes I like
the grounding too
um you can totally go outside in your
yard though and ground for 15-20 minutes
I mean you're not going to get the full
benefits but I'm only saying that
because you don't have to buy anything
ground
um just go out in your yard and try it
like there is a yeah there's a
significant difference that
I started feeling like once yeah once I
grounded and again I always say it might
be Placebo but if it is that's okay I'm
okay with that Placebo works too a few
other things for Sleep hygiene really
quickly uh either ear plugs I use a
company called earpiece like p-e-a-c-e
earpiece but I also I've replaced those
now with the Sleep phones that I use uh
sleep phone so I have uh it's like a
headband so I look like Alex Caruso and
uh except I have hair and uh I listen to
like this meditative soundscape sound
bath at night as I am sleeping and that
really helps with any outside noise or
just having some earplugs to help with
any outside noise in addition to that
either a sleep mask and or blackout
curtains at home I don't have the
blackout curtain so I use a sleep mask
uh doing both can be really helpful if
you live in a area with a lot of light
pollution in Ojai we don't have any
light pollution and so I don't need the
blackout curtains but that really helps
with yeah with all that artificial light
bombarding your house and speaking of
artificial light cutting the screens out
any blue light after dark is it's
critical because it so disrupts it
tricks your circadian rhythm and makes
you think that you're staring at the sun
as soon as the sun goes down put on a
pair of blue blockers and yeah that will
help dramatically don't eat uh more than
two hours I'm sorry less than two hours
before bed yes alcohol like six hours
before bed getting up in the morning
with the sun and getting some sun first
thing in the morning that's that's
really good to kind of help restate your
circadian rhythm and looking toward the
sun in the morning when I go outside in
the morning it's not it's still dark out
when I'm outside but as soon as the Sun
starts coming up I'll go outside and do
my stretches I'm looking toward the sun
in the morning not staring directly at
it but looking toward the Sun what that
does is it notifies your body oh it is
morning we are awake we've reset our
circadian rhythm and as the sun is
coming up like you can totally look over
the horizon and get some yeah get some
good Rays did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free